the european parliament has condemned
russia's invasion of ukraine calling it
illegal unprovoked and unjustified
in their resolution voted at an
emergency session in brussels meps also
condemned the involvement of belarus
which has allowed russia to use its
territory as a staging post
the message from europe is clear
we will
stand up
we will not look away
when those fighting in the streets for
our values
face down putin's massive
war machine
we will support the international
criminal court's jurisdiction
and investigation of war crimes in
ukraine addressing the parliament via
video link from kiev the ukrainian
president welcomed eu help and called
for more support and more solidarity
since russia invaded on the 24th of
february the united nations says
hundreds of civilians have been killed
and hundreds of thousands
displaced men women children are dying
once again
because a foreign leader president putin
decided that their country ukraine has
no right to exist and we will never ever
let that happen and never ever accept
that
members expressed their solidarity with
ukrainians and welcomed the response of
ukraine's neighbors keeping their
borders open and helping refugees
they called for more protection for the
most vulnerable including women children
the sick and disabled
we are putting maximum pressure on
russia and its leaders we are stepping
up to support ukraine and the ukrainian
people
mep meps backed the eu's unprecedented
sanctions against the regime of vladimir
putin but said the eu needed to go
further restricting imports of oil and
gas
they expressed their support for the eu
providing lethal defensive equipment and
the banning of the kremlin-backed
propaganda channels rt and sputnik
parliament also called on eu
institutions to work towards granting
ukraine candidate status after its
request to join the european union